soon if all goes according to plan there
will be a special place in the valley to
help families impacted by down syndrome
it's called gigi's playhouse victoria
saha is here to tell us more about it
victoria
sasha gigi's playhouse held an event in
town today in anticipation of what's to
come gigi's playhouse will provide
everything from educational resources to
career advice to families with children
and adults living with down syndrome
can you blow kisses
go kiss us
jet is almost five years old he was born
with down syndrome his mom adrian genuso
says he's capable of so much you know
they call him milestones i like to call
them in stones he'll get there he's just
going to do it in his own time adrian
jannuza comes to these events organized
by gigi's playhouse and finds comfort in
knowing her family isn't alone when
raising a child with down syndrome we're
all there for the same reason
to know that our kids are included that
we can all kind of come together and
use each other's sounding boards hey
this works for me why don't you try this
the cdc says every year about 6 000
babies are born with down syndrome in
the united states that's about one out
of 700 babies gigi's playhouse was first
created in illinois back in 2003 the
goal was to bring positive awareness to
down syndrome by offering free literacy
math and life skill programs for
children born with it although there are
over 40 locations nationwide bringing a
physical location to las vegas is the
goal for our local moms here gigi's play
house ultimately is a place from birth
to adulthood there's adult programs my
son's 11 and i'm looking forward to him
having a place to be especially as he
gets older
right now gigi's playhouse community in
las vegas is run by five volunteer moms
they're hoping to open their physical
location in 2022 but they still need
help from the community if you would
like to donate there will be a link up
at eight newsnow dot com in the meantime
they will continue hosting pop-up events
for families to take part in